when he was with the thunder  before going to houston made it to the  conference finals a couple times  we'll see 90 seconds to go in the  quarter lakers with possession up 10.  lebron james closing in on a  triple-double kuzma hanks can't finish  but lebron over the top  with a one-handed stuff  [Music]  the put back slam by lebron james  i couldn't do that when i was 39 i  couldn't do that this late in my career  i couldn't do it when i was 29.  i've never done it so but 36 years old  18th year in the league  and just look at the way he maintains  his body is lewis with two to shoot  lost it out of bounds i mean  six-year-old how many games does this  guy play  yeah you know there's going to be some  contact it just doesn't matter he rises  above the  defender and puts it back with the  emphatic jam and you see on the video